[Music]
let's go let's go mr. David Ingmar and
Adam left go how you feeling I'm on the
podcast show every get the freestyling
but I'm gonna do my best cuz you love
freewheeling I don't know great that was
not you're not prepared I wasn't gonna
happen well no I actually I just cleared
one of my inboxes so that felt really
while the intro song was going you can
freestyle and multitask apparently yeah
okay ah that's awesome and I'm also
working on my posture yeah that's an
important thing you want to know the
trick get your shoulders all the way
back and drop them Olinda I'm a ballet
my fiance said pretend that someone is
pulling a string in the back of your
head and then pretend like you're all
hanging from that stream you look super
natural right now this is if you're
watching on YouTube that's a lot of
phrase no because my posture sucks yeah
it's a it's a thing you gotta you gotta
have I'm not great about it core muscles
definitely definitely a thing I think
about a lot I'm actually realizing this
right now this podcast is coming out on
a Thursday which means this Saturday
will be the 33rd day of the eat like a
homie challenge so on Saturday I'm gonna
give you on Sunday too if you guys want
to hit up the social at left Co show and
this is Twitter or on Instagram but
really Instagram cuz you guys can all DM
me on Instagram send me the before and
the after remember if you're taking
pictures of the scale cuz you don't want
to put yourself on social I completely
get it just wear some socks wear some
socks show me the before picture in the
after picture if you want to include a
story awesome and then next Thursday
I'll get to some of the best so I can
get through all them and I'll actually
be in town so to everyone that's done
the e like a homie challenge
congratulations
yeah and if you if you've discovered a
new recipe or a new genre of food
you're eat like a homie days and you
know your journeys let us know yeah just
discovered cajun shrimp for the first
time i don't know it's up it's also
recipe so that happened we are gonna
have danny green an interview with him
coming up in a little bit and it was a
good conversation 12 minutes long pretty
much with a guy that just won the
championship so we were so happy to get
time with him but first we need to do
some real business and there's only one
sound that i'm talking about
[Applause]
big offseason you bet your ass it is
alright ingmar where we started we're
only gonna do three this week okay i
usually count down our top five we're
gonna do three this week cuz we want to
get to Danny Green yes who by the way if
you've ever seen like a six foot seven
person walk through a you know just like
walk through a big crowd of people
holding the Larry O'Brien trophy it's
the coolest entrance I've ever seen
really yes it was like a wrestler making
an entrance with the belt it's like a
baby that people actually care about was
shiny cuz you're holding it and he's so
gentle with it and then everyone's just
like oh my god it was it was cool
anyway I like that he calls them Larry's
yeah yeah he was - Larry's yeah and I
put a bow Tanic on Lawrence alright so
we've got three we're gonna count it
down from three number three QB Lamar
Jackson who he was called not just the
fastest quarterback in the league but he
might be the fastest player period by
the Baltimore Sun the reporter said the
reporter said that okay now this was
created the what would watch urn Alissa
what grabbed me about this was the
headline the headline was confident yet
inconsistent QB Lamar Jackson taking
command of the Ravens offense that's
pretty whoa pretty well that's pretty
whoa that like you know the quarterback
who's now had a half season as a starter
you know fared pretty well in the fourth
quarter of a playoff game you know did
his thing yes wasn't necessarily gonna
win but did his thing and then you know
now he's taking command of the offense
it's kind of like the Cuyler Murray
thing he knows the offens better than
anyone you know he's taking come in I
would say that if everyone in the NFL
ran a 40-yard dash I think Lamar would
be in the top 20 Wow
which I because I think when you look
back at Louisville in the fact that he
ran a 4-3 for we never got to see him at
the combine but this is a man that
everyone says is genuinely faster than
everybody else what's interesting is I'm
realizing that Lamar is one of these
players that is gonna dominate offseason
headlines mhm
talked about last year where they were
screaming on the sidelines I talked
about a few weeks last week Earl Thomas
was saying he's blockbuster Mike Vick
was on this very show talking about how
Lamar could be the next Michael Vick
yeah
the thing about Lamar that I'm realizing
I have a dichotomy with how I think
about Lamar Jack's okay on one side this
is the time of the year when there's no
defense and there's no tackling and and
you're throwing to open people where
Lamar is going to shine right oh yes a
seven Hannon for an arm he can make all
the throws when he needs to and then
when he runs you go
what can this guy not do but the thing
that we saw with Lamar is when defenses
in the NFL can prepare for him and
disguise and confuse can he make the
throws that need to be made the other
part that I have with him is he's going
into his second [ __ ] year and they
went on like a seven-game winning streak
last year and he carried them to the
playoffs as a rookie coming in midway
through the season replacing Joe Flacco
who publicly said in the beginning of
the year I'm not gonna do anything to
help this guy and then was able to carry
them through and play in really tough
situations like I'm thinking about that
too like mahomes had his breakout year
in his second year he didn't play in his
first year right so I'm simultaneously
going were hyping him up too much and
then I'm going man if this was a
talkative guy that didn't play in
Baltimore maybe he'd be getting more
hype right now we're gonna lie on this
back somewhere in them I'm a [ __ ]
even fine right down the middle right
down the middle
because I don't I would love to go oh
wow Lamar does great in shorts and with
no defenders but then I also want to go
why are we not hyping out Lamar Jackson
more I'm
[ __ ] five the other thing though is
that Lamar Jackson like Michael Vick has
a career in flag football if the NFL
thing doesn't work out he'd be a great
flag football right shifty got the spin
moves going he can work in open field
seven on seven he'd be a monster my uh
it'll be interesting with Lamar I I
always want to be an advocate for Lamar
because when players don't talk a lot I
like to stand up for them but I thought
that he handled the Joe Flacco thing
perfectly last year where when they
asked him he said something to the
effect of Jose were teammates this is
not about winning we're teammates and
the team rallied around him but I love
Lamar so I would say I'm a little bit
more towards we should be hyping them up
more and bring me the whoa all right so
we're just gonna hype up Lamar on this
podcast then I like it I'm a six and a
half and a half tour tonight crate that
was number three number two your man
David Johnson oh yeah okay he said quote
I think Jeff soft-spoken guy yeah
everybody when he speaks you know it has
more employees I think Josh Rosen will
be a generational talent in this league
he will become a force with the dolphins
I think there was on the Adam shine show
it's very interesting because the reason
the Cardinals were publicly allowed to
trade Josh Rosen was Kyler was a
generational quarterback that we've
never seen before and even if you think
your guys really good you should get rid
of them if you think this guy's a
generational quarterback right so to use
that same word choice you think that was
the guy that left
I think teammates will always hype up
people in tough situations like that you
never know if they really believe that
or whatever but I think Josh Rosen can
be a great quarterback in this league I
don't know what you think about Josh
Rosen I've been a big fan ya get throw a
nice deep ball yeah he seems savvy
he seems like a cerebral guy and my
thing with Josh Rosen is if he wasn't
seen as a silver spoon in this mouth
came up wealthy that's done up I hate
that if we didn't focus so much on that
I think we'd pay more credence to the
fact that David Johnson was hurt for
most of the year they went through two
offensive coordinators Larry Fitzgerald
who's like 72 years old was his only
reliable target Rickey seals Jones and
jerk we're not like his offensive line
was a mess we haven't given Josh Rosen
any help
so David Johnson saying this it's
interesting cuz I'm sure some people in
Arizona like some shock jocks go and
does this mean he doesn't believe in
Kyler Murray coming up next to Johnny in
the Dukes I'm just gonna do drops after
every time you do the radio voice what
is a generation is it 15 years is it 20
years great follow-up because the the
NFL's been around for a hundred years
and does that mean there have been only
five generational quarterbacks in the
history of the NFL I feel like there's
more than now like and Drew Brees and
Tom Brady are essentially the same age
the same age which one is generational
of those three they're clearly you know
they were born within a few years of
each other it's interesting I feel like
we do this a lot with the NBA we're in
the 70s we go okay that was Julius
Erving the 80s we go magic and bird the
90s we go Michael the early 2000s we go
Kobe the late 2000s 2010's we got bran
the early 2000s we go Tim Duncan thank
you very much Tim Duncan Shaq
you know there's I'm going Tim Duncan
Shaq big ticket what's really funny is I
really think that air is dominated by
Keiji Latrell Sprewell in Allen Iverson
when you think of the end when I just go
through everything but with the NFL yeah
it's like do you give that generation to
paint in there Tom right I it's the word
generational we've just we've taken it
we've co-opted the word generational to
mean superlative or excellent or you
know once every few years but it's not
once every few years because pretty much
every year there's one or two really
good quarterbacks that come out of the
draft sometimes two or three right yes
Tom Brady has he owned the last two
generations you know where does Aaron
Rodgers fit in where's Brett Favre fit
into this right yeah it's it's a it's a
word that has carried more weight than
he is a great quarterback yeah and
people hear it and they stop if people
if David Johnson had just said like you
know what I think Josh Rosen is gonna do
a great job in Miami people would have
said all right that's a perfectly nice
quote nice little sound bite it's a nice
thing to say it's funny to think of what
words could he have said that would have
stopped people if he would have said
flash we've seen he's a flatulent
correct we would have been like wow that
shot but Josh Rosen is a generational
quarterback it makes you feel something
yeah Josh Rosen is a super bowl-winning
quarterback that would stop people
people would go
oh he thinks he's capable of winning
Super Bowls [ __ ] Nick Foles
like Blake bortles was one game away
from competing for a Super Bowl like
Trent until firs a Super Bowl winning
quarterback don't I mean but what other
words could he have said you know the
the most damning one that he could have
said that would still seem positive Josh
Rosen he'll be a great fantasy
quarterback he said that he just dropped
that like that would just be the
cruelest faint praise he's like
definitely a fantasy winning quarterback
yeah I mean if he would have said that
he's a true leader that actually I think
makes you look at Kyler you go oh what
are you saying about Kyle that's the
other thing right so it's like if if he
had said something about how Josh Rosen
is what is he like six-four six-five if
he had said something but he just got
that he got quarterback body then
everyone would take that as a dig on
Kyler right he's a tall quarterback he's
a real tall quarterback at that it is it
is interesting and as I said before I'm
rooting for Josh Rosen to succeed I'm
rooting for Kyler to succeed I'm just
rooting for Rosen to succeed a little
bit more than Kyler because I think he's
been treated like [ __ ] and I and if Josh
wrote if Kyler Murray wins one I want
Josh Rosen win - sure that's just how
I'm looking at it right there's a finite
number of Super Bowls to be one out
there it's okay to say that you're
rooting for people more than other
people that's totally fine sure yeah my
hands up in the air by the way for the
bucket all right we are down to the last
one right yeah which means it's time for
whoa the offseason ding burrs hammer
brace your face that was a drop that was
made by a listener of your John John
Bar chard who is he see techie like
texted me an audio note of how to
rightly say his name because I was
making him French John bar chart bar sh
bartered bartered John barter like
Orchard yeah who's a big time radio host
down in Philadelphia that WIP so took a
little time out of his schedule to make
you drop says he's part of the 33% I'm
[ __ ] down respect down so number one
this is the hammer what is it this is
your man Jonathan Abram yeah I'm so
happy he got paid I know the man got
paid in six plus million on the signing
bonus
beautiful 11 plus million for four years
beautiful just lock this dude up he's
gonna be a monster he's playing well
he's playing with the the first
stringers already first stringers making
a freestyle look I'm looking at like
this he's already leading the freestyles
they went on a freestyle anymore he's
coming for people's necks I go on vantes
perfect Instagram and he's posting
multiple pictures and multiple different
times with Jonathan Abram saying we
gonna do big things this year I'm seeing
LaMarcus Joyner claiming that he's like
his younger brother of all the rookies
Cleveland Farrell was supposed to come
in there and be the leader Josh Jacobs
is supposed to be Gruden's pound the
rock guy the veterans on the Raiders are
loving our boy Jonathan Abram beautiful
baby boom and you know it when you see
it I remember I played JV I'm gonna call
right now yours in a column I have not
told them I'm gonna do it all my phone
and make it speakerphone but keep
talking about JV basketball oh just that
like you know the the kids on JV sat in
the front half of the bus and the kids
and varsity sat in the back and we had a
freshman that made varsity he just like
went over to hang out the back okay he
picked up hey Abram I literally just
called you because I'm recording the
podcast so don't think anything stupid
but we wanted to congratulate you on
signing a contract way to [ __ ] go
congratulations
yeah that's really all I got for you man
how does it feel
I love it uh are you gonna buy anything
really cool did you have your eyes on
one thing that you're like when I sign
this I'm gonna get that alright
congratulations on the let you say one
weren't you wanna see two M's in the
account dude you're about to have
multiple commas in a bank account the
two comma Club all right I'm gonna call
you later just wanted to say congrats
alright peace Jonathan a bro that was
the left go cold call of the week
couscous BRR it's cold in here super
excited for Jonathan Abram I'm happy
that he's still picking up but I'm
rooting for him all year and if let's
say like week eight there's a PFF where
it's like according to statistics
Jonathan Abram is the worst performing
rookie PFF [ __ ] like my love of
Jonathan Abramson is gonna turn up fact
fact oh that's an interesting just
ecstatic yeah they're be awful if I hit
delete on it yeah all the time
ignore alright so one thing that we
wanted to try and do which was to start
a new segment on the show before we get
to Danny Green coming up and be a
champion Danny Green where a lot of you
guys are part of the 33% and I
appreciate you but we need to recognize
when people go above and beyond the call
of duty and they don't just give their
33% they give their 133 percent right so
these aren't just woes these are people
that are going above and beyond super
woes the 133 percent and if someone out
there is gonna make a drop for us for
this could they just at some point be
like 133 percent math something like
that I just want the word math somewhere
prominently in the drop I love it so
really this show if they do 133 percent
this show comes up to a hundred and
nineteen hundred and ninety nine percent
right damn that's a lot of profit two
hundred percent I don't know which ones
you're picking so I'm gonna go with one
first and then you go with one second
okay I'm gonna go Matt Stafford a parent
on the injury report late last season
Matt Stafford was a debt it's--at back
injury nobody knew what it was the team
website writer Mike O'Hara
I guess dropped this information and
thought it had already been reported and
then people went back and realized it
had not been reported that Matt [ __ ]
Stafford let me take that back Matt
frickin Stafford you're not allowed to
swear no I just want I didn't there was
unnecessary played with a broken back
last year unbelievable he had broken
bones in his back and what I want to say
is is of all the quarterbacks in the NFL
Matt Stafford has become one of the guys
that gets discussed a lot and brought
down a lot and made fun of a lot because
of his lack of postseason success and
how people believe that he's overrated
all I know about Matt Stafford is
there's the NFL Films clip from his
rookie year where he finished a drive
with a broken arm like a the separated
shoulder and now we're finding out that
he played the end of last year bro the
last month of the year did not really
matter for the Lions they were not in
the playoff hunt right and Stafford's
going out there and playing with a
broken fricking back and if you've ever
tweaked your back I mean you know how
debilitating it is even just a minor
thing just a soreness just a slip disc
this dude was out there with a broken
back playing yeah the throwing the sax I
just want to say Stafford now that we
know this thank you for giving your 133
percent for sure that's like a
historical 133 percent to look back yeah
but it just came out that's why I'm sure
it to him yeah for me I kind of have one
sort of fun one and one more serious
okay I don't know we haven't established
the paradigm of what you know we don't
know exactly what one 33 is I guess I
went serious I'll go serious no no go
fun one I'll go with the fun one okay I
get a sandwich I was reading about you
know I just love reading about the the
training camps that's going on right now
and how Mike Vrabel is keeping it light
oh yeah keeping it light so hundred
thirty three percent to defense a
coordinator the Titans Dean P's who
caught a punt to win a contest against
the offensive coordinator oh that's all
so they were doing the like you know old
guys OC vs. DC yes got to catch a punt
midair Dean P's does it this is a big
thing at the end of practice right like
a coach will go I'm gonna they typically
put up like a defensive lineman
they go if you catch this punt we get to
leave you no one does sprints so they
brought the coordinators out they were
out the coordinators out which I just
love that that that feels very on brand
for variable yes right he's got his
deputies out there you guys are gonna go
out there bus your rest and we're gonna
throw star s to so I love that it was
kind of a ver able gets 17% Dean P's get
16% he caught it he caught it
did the other guy catch it I don't even
know Arthur Smith is the OC okay he did
not catch it so the the place I'm
assuming whatnot they went absolutely
crazy they were mobbing him and the
reporter apologized it was from the
Tennessee and I can't rember who the
reporter is but he said probably Palka
har ski basically said that that Mike
Vrabel has a vibe of Rage Against the
Machine mosh pit in practice right now
why I love it
Titans are a sleepy team Titans and
Panthers are two of the hardest teams
for me to predict right now cuz I don't
know the health of their quarterback
right but I look at the Titans and I go
man if that line with Derek Henry and
and all those wide receivers they just
got and and you know I keep seeing
development and that defense with four
able I just did just unlike goals are so
good on a rainy afternoon just watch
Derek Henry high school clips on YouTube
no dude it is something to behold it's
on par with like watching Iverson high
school football highlights Derek Henry
is just truckin I would just imagine
it's like the Terminator like he bust
through a guy and just it's pretty close
to that like in a cartoon when like nine
guys are draped all over someone and
he's still running for extra yards
unbelievable he ran for something like
4,000 yards my other 133 percent math
apparently cornerback for the I went
very serious the cornerback for the
Colts Kenny Moore a henge a hedge fund
chief says that not only did Kenny Moore
save his son's dog but by doing so he
may have saved his son Kenny Moore
parent well this guy that the hedge fund
guys name is Drew Dixon his son max
apparently was battling depression all
the time so much so that he called him
suicidal and apparently they were in
Costa Rica and on the scraps of a trash
heap
he found like an abused and terrified
puppy named chica he called it chica
okay and his son threw rehabilitating
chica
regained his love for life that's
beautiful so let's let's all realize
what that is you're on the streets of
Costa Rica and a dog
simultaneously saves you as you save the
dog apparently they move to Indianapolis
and chica doing what all dogs do chasing
a squirrel hit by a car driver speeds
off dog left there to die
Kenny Moore pulls up opens his door gets
out of the car goes up to the son says I
got you picked up a bloody formerly
discarded dog throws it into his car
goes to a veterinarian goes to a surgeon
saves the dog's life and the words the
father probably saved his son's life
that's 133% right there holy [ __ ] see
now I feel dumb for having chosen like a
punt catching contest this is like I
don't I don't know what I was real I
can't I'm honest and I was but for me
you know he just Kenny Moore just signed
a very sizable contract with the Colts
and then I like when good [ __ ] happens
to good people so when I heard that yeah
I guess I got a moat I got I got a
little tense sure damn I like it yeah I
want to give a shout out to three homies
forgiven they're 133 percent one
Mitchell Penske who is always making art
and if you go into the IG page at left
Co show you'll see some of the Vic art
that he did to come and commemorate him
being on the show I want to give a shout
out to Vincent and if I say your name
wrong I apologize with Jaya who did that
left go show art where it's me Bart
Scott Charles Barkley and Ernie Johnson
sitting on a couch cartoon like he just
did that bro like I appreciate your 133
percent and I don't know if I ever gave
credit to wood master 5000 for
officially shaving his eyebrows for us
so that is on the IG left go show if you
scroll down a little bit but would
master 5,000 I appreciate you actually
going through bro and shaving those
eyebrows and if you want to make another
bet on Blake Chara win this year I am
happy to do it
strong strong handle to a wood master
5000 just a strong yeah
coming up wood master 5000
alright your other one 33% yes this one
is a little more in the serious side of
things but it's uplifting Arik Armstead
of the 49ers yes he's got a really cool
charity going I mean a lot of these guys
have great charities but they all have
different they all have different
motivations and this one's really
focused on literacy which i think is
really great for an athlete to be
promoting literacy a lot with young kids
kids from the inner city they see them
they probably they haven't does a lot of
like sports related things and you know
getting the kids off the street there's
all these amazing different charities
that are happening but I just really
like that this athlete said I'm really
gonna focus on getting these kids to
read more because as he noted Armstead
shared these sobering numbers this is
from the the SAC b.com story more than
two-thirds of students who are not able
to read proficiently at the end of 4th
grade will end up on welfare or jail
Armstead also hosted his annual football
camp with 200 kids attending a man in
his element surrounded by giddy kids
locked on his every word he stressed
fitness fun reading and living a good
life at any age that's lovely I
appreciate all four of those hundred
thirty three percent we're gonna coming
up in July I'm gonna do the left go good
guys again we're I'm pretty much gonna
try and find a guy from almost every
team that's doing stuff because as we've
talked about here at bleacher report and
I've kind of explained to them we are
about to enter the time where you guys
are going to see a lot of NFL players
getting in trouble but you need to have
the paradigm that while it seems like a
lot compared to the greater number of
the amount of athletes in the league it
is a small fraction do not let the media
paint it as though man 3 OS arrests in
one week the NFL is really going to the
birds just I like to do it as a reminder
that yes if seven guys get in trouble
over this offseason that we're about to
go into there's thirty five hundred
players in the league and there are so
many more that are leading communities
than being the black eye for where they
grew up so just as this goes on there
will be a rest the next few weeks sure
people will get busted for something
people will get in trouble for something
else it's going to happen it happens
every year don't get caught up in the
Goodell has an epidemic on his hands
I grew up in a town with only 7,000
people right and I assumed that several
people would get arrested every week
it's a town right if you think about the
NFL as like a small town yes and there's
you know half a dozen people get
arrested it's like yeah that doesn't say
anything about the larger population
it's just a couple of people got
arrested there was a kid in my town that
put poop in the sauce at PI listening
and apparently they found out and they
shut down the Pizza Hut and I'd like to
say to that kid
[ __ ] you it was my favorite rest you
just deprived people of pizza which is a
crime in and of itself it also made me
think back how many years did I actually
poop and with that let's go to Danny
Green we got a chance to interview Danny
Green in front of a live audience and it
was a lot of fun again I got a chance to
work with Danny Green around the NBA
all-star game so here is a nice little
short conversation with an NBA champion
Danny Green of the Toronto Raptors thank
you guys I did not get enough can I get
more love please for the NBA champion
Danny freakin great
hey that's not too bad not too bad so
you guys Danny I went back and I watched
your 2014 championship and you're going
down the Riverwalk San Antonio Spurs and
you had a t-shirt on and glasses man I
see you on this parade you got the fro
out you got the cigar hair tell me how
special was this championship how did
this feel very man especially because it
you know five years to get back to this
final stage being traded to a whole
different country and not just playing
for myself with 36 million people in the
country and those within the states that
looking for you know the Toronto Raptors
so there's Canadian fans everywhere when
ou said being with Hawaii coming off an
injury getting older having a whole new
coach staff and just having a group that
did it one year together you know
gelling so fast and it was probably the
toughest one so it was really hard
that's why I makes it so much special
you joked in the the parade I'm the one
that you guys forgot about was in the
trade cuz everyone talking I was just
the other guy in the tree
yeah Grayson yeah but not other guy I'm
curious
nobody really knows anything about Kauai
and y'all come over together I think
they do now now it's starting to come
out board man gets paid yeah but for you
did you guys have like a shared mindset
like we're gonna try and bring something
to this Raptors team I mean I think
that's always been our everywhere we've
gone every every season we played it
started on the defensive end of the
floor you know we was as younger kids we
started on San Antonio we wanted to be a
you know hang our hat on that into the
floor what's up boy
I mean oh so every time I step on the
floor we want to do the best defensive
Wings in the game and we knew we had a
shot when we had you know surge chalo
and we had a lot of other guys that can
you know switch down the line oh gee
defensively I was leading to a core I
could do offensively and I know I could
shoot sometimes yeah so we knew that
would help but um you know we knew we
had the potential to be some special
especially with Pascal becoming the way
he was
you know nothing short of amazing humbly
incredibly improved from year to year so
we knew we had a very good opportunity
and chance to make it all I hear in this
league it's a star driven League and
then I look at your team and its glue
guy glue guy glue guy new guy glue guy
you got a couple stars there oh no no no
no they're there they're there but I'm
curious when you win right and there's
that moment where you realize the
season's over
and we get to walk around New York City
with the Larry O'Brien trophy was it any
more special looking at the other guys
and go and Kyle Lowry has a ring Marcos
soul has a rim is sure that that's what
made it more special for me and I was so
much more happy for those guys who have
been in the league for so long I never
got a chance to experience like a Marcus
all um you know Kyle Lowry who's been
knocked out of playoffs early a lot of
times by the same team yeah um and then
some of the younger guys who accept a
big for us you know Fred vanvleet
Norman Powell you know Pascal was most
improved and then obviously you know me
and kawaiii going through a lot of you
know different stuff throughout the
summer time or different teams it search
had been leaked for so long so instead a
lot of those coaches who were new
coaches young but they've been all over
the world coaching and overseas yeah
been everywhere really happy and it's
been special for them because of what
they've been through when you're a free
agent there's a lot of stuff up in the
air when you win a championship and then
you're a free agent
does it make it easier does it change
the way that you approach it
um maybe but I don't think it depends on
really a lot of other people I should
say and not just Kauai but for agency
free agency is dictated on a lot of the
stars and obviously with a be going to
LA that dictates a lot changed a lot of
free agency just that open your eyes a
little bit I'd open I mean a lot of
people's eyes and a lot of team's eyes
so free agency just changed because of
that one trade
so you're gonna sit back and watch
everybody I'm gonna have to I have to
wait till the stars go where they go and
then and then the teams come to other
guys say oh we need this piece we need
that piece is it positional like is
there one guy you're like he'll be the
Domino to fall for me it's small forward
or is it just stars in general it's star
in general I think each team look for
those guys first what pieces they need
and within the stars and then from there
they figure out what other pieces to add
- yeah they'll complement those stars
you know I'm a Sixers fan and you know
and you hey man y'all got the four
bounces go I put it in I was incredible
yeah I hear everyone talk about Toronto
and Jurassic Park and it's a story line
that we all see but like is it different
for you as a player like is it truly
different that is the international
experience oh for sure I don't think he
realized how different cuz when you get
when you're there it seems like just
like New York right um oh but until you
go around carrying different money they
use in Celsius you know a lot of things
are very different than bags o bags milk
bag milk they have a lot of things that
are different and when you go to a steak
house they don't have a one sauce you
know I just realized I have a vital
question to ask you is the Kauai Apple
Time story true no I don't you don't
think so do you know how badly we all
want him to sit down at dinner and go
Apple time Apple time and they need a
dozen habit I think people are just
making up stories just randomly of it
but some of them are true he is a funny
guy but he says short phrases but I've
never seen that happen never side with
him since the service career I don't
remember him at our dinners having a bag
of apples and just cutting them up into
you damn existential question for you
and a game 6 you make a pass goes off
the fingertips of Pascal Sock'em that
will never be remembered it's a whole
race from the history I hope not what
made it from Bleacher Report we delete
it we handle it we talked to the inner
you know how to play by play yeah yeah
when they go to like greatest games that
won't be on there what is it like to
have a play where in that moment you're
like holy crap what did I just do and
then the game ends and no one's ever
gonna bring it up - no it's an emotional
roller coaster demands that you go from
suicide watch - oh Jesus my life is
saved you know so um you know I was
really happy that they saved me it was
still very hard to enjoy it at
it took a while for me to yeah let that
play go but um you know I'm just glad
that they saved me I've had a great time
I got to do the rookie sophomore game I
was doing play-by-play he was doing
color so we got a chance to work
together that day a lot from this guy
hey man I'm the one I'm the I could be
your sensei
but I see you head-to-toe right now on
Puma and I like when certain athletes
get sponsored when I know they're good
people to this relationship what were
you wearing on your feet like how has
this thing blossomed and always been
amazing man all year Pumas supported me
and come and give me all types of new
gear colorways and make sure I'm taken
care of and obviously you know they got
the jet so I get to use that sometimes
oh we're all start how I came to the X
that's how you got there got to all
study at Puma let me use the jet but you
got the change we're making it to the
finals yeah our Eastern Conference
Finals
they've take really good care of us man
I got a custom custom I was gonna wear
him to it with some custom title runs
you know had we the champs on it when
they have theirs you know claw coming
out of it was really nice that they've
done an amazing job all year long and
what is your relationship right now with
that object with left
yeah with Larry me and Larry oh cool
you're cool right we're getting closer
closer do you just sit and look at it
like is it like a newborn do you think
we're just gonna like kiss it for no
time the first time gotcha this time I
still you don't get used to it you don't
know but you try to meet as many Larry's
as you can in your lifetime make as many
friends of him and his twin brothers
closest you've seen anyone - dropping
Larry O'Brien
actually somebody did drop Larry O'Brien
Toronto Raptor did know and I wrapped it
okay this is in San Antonio so I don't
know who was it's not gonna say but uh
so they let you don't know if they're
gonna do this in Toronto but we want
I guess cuz Saints won't want so many
they knew how I went there like a lot of
foreign guys they're like we're gonna
let you guys take the trophy
yeah that can trophy cuz they got one
and they get you get two because they
usually put one of the practice ility in
one in the arena gotcha so one of them
they kept at home they took the second
one is it all right we'll let you guys
take it for a certain amount of time
each player gets it these dates you pick
dates you want and you know you could
bring around you it was bad it was guys
had any countries like no tie rod in
Brazil and
yeah I was went back to France and I
brought it to Long Island New York this
one from but when I got it there's
actually a dent in it cause I don't know
who dropped it was my drop there was a
dent in it but I think they had to
replace it or whatever fix it however
they got it done but man somebody did
drop it
all right last thing because I people
want to meet you and get autographs and
all that if you had to kind of boil this
down the thing that you learned about
yourself through this journey oh man
just you know that uh regardless of the
situation regardless of the system you
got to be adaptable adjustable and I
think I've been able to I still learned
a lot even from being the older guy from
the younger guys I've learned a lot from
being a new system I'm trying to be the
veteran yeah different role in a locker
room and I learned that you know I
couldn't I didn't I kind of questioned
myself dad myself to see how well I can
change an atmosphere to change the
locker room yeah but uh knowing and
seeing what we've accomplished I know I
can have an impact on younger guys and I
never thought I whatever would be a
coach I don't want to be a coach right
right right but I think I could be good
at it I think I could you know said make
a hell of a free agency pitch hope I can
come to your locker room I think I have
some veteran leadership that can help me
it may have been sometimes in the court
where I didn't do great but I think in
the locker room I kept guys positive
mindset and help them mature to become
you know what a winning atmosphere and
on winning culture over there this
number is two cuz that's the amount of
Championships that Danny Green has can I
get a round of applause for the Green
Ranger thank you guys thank you yeah how
do you like your chip stance with the
dude oh nice
always great to see Danny I have no idea
what's gonna happen with him in free
agency but if I'm ever able to get him
in studio that was an event so I
couldn't really talk to him too much
about football I just want to know where
his football allegiances lie he grew up
in Long Island so I feel like he might
be a Giants fan but I don't know
I also liked he showed a lot of love to
the toronto fans and the san antonio
fans yes i like when guys do that cuz
you want to believe when some guy moves
on from your favorite team that let's
say you've been there for five six seven
years you want to believe that he still
has love for that
that loved him so much and he got traded
it's not like he just left he was right
exactly he showed genuine love for both
fan bases and I really dug that about
him all right so we have done which list
right now for the quarterbacks we've
done snare child rankings
stepdads and Hunger Games right and I
have decided that this week's
quarterback rankings because we had
Danny Green on he's a basketball player
and it's summertime it's summertime not
the first thought was starting NFL QB
dunk rankings but what I realized was
all the smaller guys are gonna get
screwed and we're just gonna have Drew
Brees and Kirk Cousins and all these
people at the bottom let's just remember
though that spud Webb won a dunk contest
John Wall wanted dunk contest basketball
players though it's true but I'm saying
if Cuyler Murray did the exact same dunk
as Josh Allen it would look more
impressive yes calimary and he'd get
more points from the what we're gonna do
because I know a lot of you are gonna do
this this summer we are doing starting
NFL quarterbacks damn it we are doing
starting NFL quarterbacks pool dunk
rankings splash nice so what it really
is is ranking how do you think the NFL
quarterbacks would rank if they were
doing dunks in a pool right everyone's
gonna do this summer and one of the
first things I thought about was man
like do I really think that Ryan
Fitzpatrick and then I thought you know
I bet you Ryan Fitzpatrick's gonna have
like that secret dunk that no one's seen
and Freleng throws it behind his back
catches it and then like splashes out
the pool and like the fitzpatrick like
like a look yeah he has the showmanship
where he might actually be up there so
there's there's criteria if you don't
mind cuz you haven't made your list yet
no no no I'm just shooting the [ __ ]
right cuz you have to you have to sort
of establish some criteria at least for
me like I love that you do this yeah for
me that eagerness is definitely up there
right like because if someone's too cool
for school right I think a couple of
these quarterbacks they might be like
I'm not dunking in the pool you know the
guy at the pool party that's just like
sitting on a lot of Roethlisberger's
taking his shirt off you know what I
mean so like I don't know like that's
another thing too my problem with been
robbed and we're gonna get to my ideas I
think that Roethlisberger
is gonna destroy your hoop but uh I
wouldn't doesn't he seem like a hoop
hanger yeah not my problem you got a
cheaper fisher-price crap
all right wait so what are your
guidelines uh jumping abilities is
obviously huge because more hang time
yet but this is both vertical and broad
jump right you need to get like that
vertic umming off the side yes be able
to get a lot of horizontal as well
creativity right improvisation and super
big and then I think this is like an
underrated part of a pulldown
the ability to assemble a fun a screw
for multi person dunks ah that's pretty
good yeah Aaron Rodgers is doing solo
missions but Josh Allen might throw it
to say I'm darn old who might throw it
to Baker see what I'm saying
I'm actually I was thinking like cities
and teams that like Jared Goff might be
able to put like just that offense seems
like a bunch of fun young things like he
gets Kooks involved he know you're
bringing another team as a big-time pool
party I'm well yeah Jared Goff holds a
pool host a pool party and doesn't bring
his offensive skill position players
like they're gonna be pissed I didn't
think about that I'm just I'm just
throwing it up yeah you have a major
list y'all rock this out okay so what
are some things that came to your mind
Josh Allen of course 33 and a half inch
vertical 119 inch broad jump that's
pretty good which is actually one inch
more than Josh Allen's broad jump I see
Josh Allen chugging a beer going on
between the legs behind like the head
he'll get props yeah yeah and go through
a table oh yeah right like rubra maybe
jump off of a table jump off of the
table and then through a different table
it's pretty good
Andy Dalton I feel like just most of the
redheads in my life don't like to spend
all day perfecting a dunk with their
shirt off Micah sunburn might get some
super-society should you just be
factored in I'm saying yeah bring your
aloe vera I'm gonna add in that Derek
Carr is gonna be very high on my list if
you guys remember Derek Carr would have
pool basketball games against Khalil Mak
hmm and so I and he claims that he's
dunked on Khalil Mac in a pool so I know
that Derek Carr he's used to it like
he's got the familiarity down which is
very important in my ranking Khalil Mac
would probably be my number one for the
base of playing pool chicken Wow
shoulders miles carrots up there too
because Aaron Donald cool max what is
six-six you got that like the nice high
leverage coleus Campbell is perfectly
good on my shoulders on him
I mentioned Big Ben would destroy your
hoop Jared Goff could assemble a really
great LA crew I mean what what a thing
that would be if he could get some like
celebrity LA fans get Magic Johnson
involved the Jack Nicholson involved and
just like create like a celebrity pool
dunk on it out of nowhere McVeigh steps
up takes his sunglass and goes that was
cooks to woods to guff dunk man he
remembers everything
and then finally Patrick mahomes I just
like the idea of no-look passes and
you're in your group pool dunks
blindfold dunk by mahomes that's what
I'm saying so this is gonna be really
hard there there's a lot of good
candidates rivers not dunk he just yells
at the young kids for running at the
pool right yes when you have nine kids
you don't go in the pool you you sit on
a high chair with zinc oxide on your
nose and you look down at the pool and
you make sure that everyone's safe
Tom Brady Tom Brady watches other people
dunk and then gets super angry and then
spends the entire year only focused on
getting better at pool dunking it's like
hey did you hear that Tom Brady missed
like four weeks of practice yeah
apparently he's just in his backyard
perfect pool dunks Kyler might be up
there because I think Kyler might be the
one dude that's like young and reckless
enough to do like a front flip done he's
a multi-sport athlete multi-sport
athlete all right this is exciting so
you guys and then Eli gets the shaft in
every list that should be the running
gag yeah that's what it is we're waiting
to find the list where Eli shoots to the
top most likely quarterback best at
catching flies in his mouth so you guys
hit me up on social hit me up on my
personal one Adam left Co and let me
know what I need to know for the
quarterback rankings before I do them
for best pool dunker fun episode a
little bit of whoa 133 where we got very
emotional
quarterback rankings and interview a
Danny Green Nick play that funky music
appreciate all of you guys homies for
bringing your 33% love y'all very much
next week I am NOT gonna be here but we
already have a podcast in the can it
will be good it is with Ross Tucker so
all the Tuck hetz and the Tucker's I
guess will be
Engelbert have a great weekend you too
enjoy yourself
thank you as always love y'all holla
holla holla see you later
[Music]